It's great to welcome to the program today.
Eric Kaufman, who is professor of politics
at Birkbeck. Yep.
University of London in the UK. Also author
of white shift, populism, immigration and
the future of white majorities. Uh, Eric,
great to have you on today. Great to be here,
David. So let's, I mean how, what's the best
way when someone doesn't know about the discussions
that are taking place in political circles
and anthropological circles in many circles
about the future of race divisions or or sort
of the racial makeup of modern Western countries
including the United States. What is the kind
of top line change that we're seeing and what
we expect racial makeup to look like in 25
and 50 years?
Well, many, many Americans are, are obviously
familiar with the figure of roughly half of
Americans won't be non Hispanic whites around
2050 that's, that's been known for a while.
Less well known is that something similar
will occur at around the same time in Canada
and New Zealand. Uh, the changes in Canada,
which is where I'm originally from, um, are
actually quite dramatic. Some Statistics Canada
demographers showed that in 2006 the population
was about 80% white, 20% minority. And then
by 2106 a hundred years later, the proportions
are, are more or less reversed, kind of give
you, it now counted as one of the faster moving
countries. But it gives you a sense of the
changes we're, we're really only now embarking
on and that we're really gonna reverberate
around the West in Europe. It will be towards
the end of the century, at least in western
Europe that the majority minority point we'll
will arrive. But this is, these are just a
sense of a set of quite monumental shifts
that are going to change our politics in great
ways.
So what has been the, uh, sort of political
reaction as people learn about this coming
change across countries? I mean, I know that
in the United States there's definitely a
right wing element that sees this as evidence
that whites are or soon will be an oppressed
minority. Potentially. This leads to arguments
about what immigration policy should be. It
stems and connect stems from and connects
to a lot of other sort of policy issues. But
is there some general way in which this shift
is being sort of interpreted by left and right
wing elements of the different countries you
mentioned?
Yeah, I think that there is a general pattern.
The, the response amongst conservatives is
one of identity threat I think, which is what's
fundamentally driving, um, right wing populism
I think across Europe and also in the US and
elsewhere. I think on the left there is an
element of the left that is sort of seizing
upon this as a sort of signal or harbingers
or that some kind of new societies is emerging
and it's sort of been bold emboldening a kind
of multicultural, what I would think is almost
a millenarian view of, of the new society
that's going to emerge sort of diverse and
equal. Um, and I think you've got a clash
of these two visions that's taking place.
And so part of this is not just the rise of
right wing populism but also a value polarization
as these visions clash.
Can you talk about that a little bit? When
you say value polarization, uh, I think most
people understand what values are and they
understand polarization, but what, what are
we talking about more specifically when values
become polarized?
Yeah. Essentially what we know from political
psychology is that there are sort of deep
rooted dispositions that people have. Um,
put bluntly, essentially some people prefer
diversity difference change, other people
prefer order continuity. The president to
be like the past, that that is sort of between
a third and a half heritable. If we look at
the literature on psychological authoritarianism
or status quo conservatism by people like
Karen Stout Stenner. Um, and what this means
therefore is that as we see these demographic
shifts are going to be processed very differently
by people who are psychologically more conservative
than those who are more open to change or
who score high on something like that. The
big five trait openness to experience. So
what we're seeing then is this divide, some
have called it open close to some of called
East somewheres anywheres. Uh, that cultural
value divide is reordering politics. It's
splitting political parties that were initially
formed on the basis of left versus right,
which are economic orientations around lower
tax, more redistribution that that older economic
cleavage in politics is being overlaid by
the stronger kind of open, close type cleavage.
Yeah. Um, uh, Jonathan Heit has some interesting
work along these lines, a as well who is,
he's probably the person who I've read most
recently on these ideas of values now do the
values carry. So let's back up a little bit.
There have been a lot of discussions that
I've had on the program about how at face
value it doesn't necessarily correlate that
a political contingent that is for low taxes
would necessarily also be against abortion,
for example, and worried about so-called oppression
against whites as a result, as well as the
result of demographic shifts. Like it doesn't
appear that there is anything obvious that
is sort of weaving those positions together
into a defined political constituency, but
is there actually something sort of underneath
the surface that does inform why those political
positions end up sort of as part of the same
voting block or or is there not?
Well, yeah, you can get ideological construction
whereby positions which probably don't necessarily
align on the sort of psychological levels
such as free markets and restricted immigration.
It's not obvious that those two things go
together at all, but you will have an ideological
package that's created by a right wing political
party or a left wing political party. They
will yolked together things that may not fit
either philosophically or psychologically.
What I would say, however, is that the pressures
from the sort of psychological value was groups
can reconfigure parties so far. Right. Parties
in Europe which used to be more low tax have
shifted more in the direction of a welfare
state. Welfare protectionism. Even in the
u s you saw that one of the big predictors
of Trump's support us as opposed to support
for other primary candidates was actually
a relatively, uh, more liberal attitude to
things like Medicare.
Um, so that sort of economically, slightly
to the left at, but culturally very concerned
about immigration. That group fractured the
Republican Party to some extent. So I think
even though, yes parties do provide these
menus of options, which are in many ways,
um, don't fit together very well, you can
get these movements that fracture that and
create new orientations amongst the parties.
So yeah, it's partly about how the, uh, political
actors slot into an fit into these dispositions.
I mean, so you could have imagined it could
be war on terror that could be mobilizing
that, that sort of, um, order seeking disposition
amongst voters. But then when the war on terror,
the Cold War fades, another division might
be mobilized. It might be the board, or for
example, um, so there are different ways of
plugging into these dispositions. The dispositions
are somewhat nonspecific. One thing we know,
however, it's certainly immigration attitudes
are heavily, uh, extremely heavily correlated
with these value dispositions.
I mean, I've looked at British and US data
and um, views on, for example, the death penalty
views on whether things in let's say things
in America were better in the past, especially
American culture was better in the past. That
has a very, very strong link to immigration
attitude. So I think it's these, some psychological
dispositions which underlie the immigration
attitudes, which underlie this sort of populist
politics and the polarization. The polarization
also arises when the kind of left liberal
side reacts to the populist right side and
thinks they are morally retrograde. Uh, and
there's, I think the whole debate there, but
that reaction to the rise of the, this right,
that provides, in addition to people responding
differently to the stimulus of diversity,
you also have this value division over, is
it even legitimate to have a conversation
about restricting immigration? Um, so that
adds just another layer to this polarizing
dynamic. It's, it's most extreme in America,
but we saw in the European elections recently
that in Europe, both populist right and the
green and liberal parties, uh, scored better
than they ever have. So that's kind of suggesting
Europe is kind of moving in that polarizing
direction.
So Eric, when it comes to the possible grievances
that one could have, um, sort of under the
umbrella of right wing populism with this
racial shift that we are, are starting to
see with the idea of possibly losing status,
which we know was a great motivator for some
Trump voters in 2016 if you had to sort of
steal man as much as possible to make the
best possible case that some or one of those
grievances is sort of backed in historical
realities or empirical realities. Do, do any
of those grievances stand up?
I actually think they do, and this may be
a place we might disagree is this. I think
that there's a real difference in the survey
data. For example, in the psychological literature
between um, hatred about groups, kind of racism
and attachment to own group. Um, now our attachment
to own group can also lead to racism if it
leads you to discriminate. But I think there's
an important distinction there. So people
can be attached to being a member of an ethnic
majority group like white American or white
British. Um, they can be attached to a particular
configuration of nationhood with, uh, ethnic
majority and minority groups, but with a particular,
um, share for each and want to conserve that.
So that's kind of our conservative orientation
based on attachment, which is I think, different
from fearing or hating and outgroup or wanting
to impress an outgroup but wanting to keep
power.
Um, so I think that's sort of how I would,
would state a lot of the impetus. Now, of
course, there are racists in, you know, most
of the populous right voters that clearly
are going to be people who simply, I hate
Muslims or, or hey, uh, Hispanics or whatever.
So, so absolutely. But there's also, we know
from certainly from Ashley Georgina's worked,
for example, on white identity politics. A
lot of voters, for example, a white Americans
who feel warmer towards whites do not feel
cooler towards blacks, let's say, or Hispanics,
then whites who don't particularly feel warm
towards whites. So the warmth towards one's
own group doesn't correlate with hostility
to the outgroup. And I think a lot of this,
there are a lot of people who are attached
to their own group are attached to their own
way of life. And it's not that different actually
from African Americans in Harlem attached
to Harlem's, African American majority. And
so the question is what we do about that,
I think, well before we leave
to what to do about it. I mean, let, let me
make sure I understand that because this is
an interesting point. If I understand you
correctly, you're saying that you can sort
of rank people based on the level of attachment
they have to their groups. So, for example,
we can take white people in the United States
or as they like to call them, European call
themselves in some groups, European Americans,
so to speak, that you might have one cohort
that has significant sort of attachment and
pride connected to being a white American
and another cohort which has less pride or
attachment to being a white American, but
that both of those groups would end up having
a sort of statistically similar feeling towards
other groups like black Americans or Hispanic
Americans or whoever that in other words,
the level of attachment to your group is not
necessarily zero sum when compared to your
feeling towards other groups.
Right, exactly. Yeah. That's quite different
site from partisan identity where if you're
a conservative and you're attached to being
conservative, you have a cooler feeling towards
liberal. So that's much more of a a zero sum
type of identity.
I guess where it becomes politically relevant
is, while that may be, correct me if I'm wrong,
while at the sort of large scale, uh, in the
aggregate that may be my sense is, and maybe
there is data to back this up, that those
who choose to become activists around keeping
the country white are probably skewed on one
side of those results in terms of how they
feel towards those in the outgroup versus
those who say, you know, my choice of activism
is not going to be around keeping the countrywide,
it's going to be around, for example, increasing
access to healthcare. I'm guessing that there
you would see some dividing lines in terms
of feelings towards outgroups. Okay.
Yeah. I mean I think in the sort of radical
segments like the KKK, you definitely would
have, you know, high white identity and, and
strong hostility to outgroups. Yes. But I
think that that I would caution against simply
dismissing the conservative element. I mean
it's not so different from wanting to conserve
a historic building or historic landmarks
or a way of life. I mean that it is going
to get expressed somehow. And I think it would
be better to talk about how quick should we
have this rate of cultural change. How can
the majority adapt? One of the things that
I say in my book is if majority's can be more
open to intermarriage interracial marriage
and adopting of mixed race people into their
group. This is a way forward because I think
you have to give the ethnic majority of vision
of itself in the future. If it's just about
your, the battled past, your toxic, you've
got decline. I don't think that's gonna. I
think that's going to lead to more polarization,
so I think talking about melting the group,
maintaining itself through through interracial
marriage, I think is one, one way forward.
I know that's not going to be accepted by
all members.
Yeah. Well, I mean, it sounds like to some
degree you're saying that there needs to be
some level of appeasement at least of the
fear that is there regardless of what it is
that is motivating that fear that it from
a pragmatic standpoint, which I like to try
to take with a lot of these issues that just
saying, hey, this is the way it's going to
be and that's, it is not a good path forward
from a pragmatic perspective. But that some
degree of appeasement, and I don't use that
word in a negative way, is uh, probably a
positive thing.
No, I mean I wouldn't call it a piece when
so much as a kind of reassurance and not,
not so much about, I'm not convinced that
it's about fear of loss of power so much.
I mean you, if you look at Europe where these
groups are more dominant in terms of, you
know, 90% of the population, it's not really
about that as much as I think a loss of this
attachment to the way things were, the country
they knew growing up, it's not the country
they recognize anymore. That kind of comes
to psychological dissonance is more the the
issue. And I think one way of getting around
that is to talk through how, uh, the consciousness,
the myths of ancestry traditions can continue
through, uh, through a mixed race population
as well, which I'm, I'm arguing that these
white majorities will become over time. I've
kind of Beijing to use Mike Lynn's term, I
think stigmatizing these groups and trying
to sort of frame them as the past and it's
something we have to supersede. That's been
a mistake amongst some progressive actors.
So I think I would prefer it to be a more
conciliatory move that allows each group to,
of have its identity rather than trying to
talk sify one a identity.
Very, very interesting stuff. We've been speaking
with Professor Eric Kaufmann, professor of
politics at Birkbeck, University of London
in the UK,
also author of the book white ship, populism,
immigration, and the future of white majorities.
Erik, really appreciate your time today.